Hausa Gomez - Peter Pan and welcome to
probably the most common thing on
YouTube is how to videos so I asked you
bros to tweet me your how to's and I
will do them let's see how it goes
how to eat your Nutella properly get a
nice little click you smear it on your
nip you make sure it's a chocolate nip
and then you like it come on don't bite
me well mom how to [ __ ] her right in the
[ __ ] [ __ ] around a project how to be
the perfect Jennifer Lawrence look-alike
just kidding it's me what are you know I
think Edgar has a crush on Jennifer
Lawrence
I don't lick an egg you get the egg you
stare it down you got a show who's boss
and then you lick it oh ah what the [ __ ]
how to have a selfie well duck face and
twerking you just want to see me do that
[ __ ] you don't actually care alright
this is how you do it this is how you do
it you like it how do not eat a banana
seductively you grab it like a man
and then you stare at it to show who's
boss and then you slowly inserted that's
seductively you select how to lose
weight in two minutes how to become
invisible that's easy
I'm still here oh yeah I need sorry I
need to I'm still here oh yeah I need to
ah ah it comes with a price but it works
every time almost every time how to hide
a pug and guy don't look at my nipples
don't don't it's not a hundred percent
accurate but you can barely see it's
trying to bite me you're crazy yeah oh
god you smell go away how to brush your
teeth with your feet you take the
toothbrush you got a nice grip is really
it's actually kind of practice I
understand right now that I'm just ish
this is so good
very practical works every time I mean
how'd I get a boyfriend
how do I stop my nipples from screaming
when I put my shirt on they are afraid
of the dark nipples are fine they're
luscious and moist as they should be put
on your shirt and as you can see my
nipples aren't crap I'll shut up and
grow a pair it's not what I meant how to
get Ebola now we're together forever
boots how to be a mermaid step 1
drop your pants step 2 get the tape step
3 be fabulous how to fist your dog don't
look at me like that well I hope you
bros learned something new today
I think you definitely did the husband
videos going up but I have been away for
a week in LA we shot with the Anki Drive
it was so much fun I had a lot of fun
meeting up with Ken and other friends
from LA but it's great to be back
I really enjoyed coming back this time
around and I felt like you bros are
there this time you bros I feel your
love and that means so much to me thank
you for always showing your support
brows I love it let's keep this up
you're doing great rose as always
there's a brofist for you now stay
awesome